welcome to the science Asylum I am Nick
lucid the question we're answering today
why do things float it has to do with
densities right oMG our chemistry class
is still pushing that nonsense there are
only three possible reasons this
misconception continues to be spread by
science teachers one they don't
understand it
I'd like to think they do with
scientists but who knows who they don't
think you can understand it let's face
it quite a few teachers and textbooks
feel this way luckily I do not and three
they're traditionalists this is how it
was taught to them so that's how they're
gonna teach it to you this act of
stubbornness is a gross violation of
what science education is supposed to be
I think it's time we put it to rest but
first we need to know why density isn't
enough to explain floating density is
always given as a mass per volume where
mass measures how much stuff is there
and volume is how much space that stuff
takes up so it sort of measures how well
a substance takes up as little space as
possible
now density can vary a little bit with
temperature so the examples I'm about to
give you are at room temperature
copper is 8960 kilograms per cubic meter
aluminum is 2,740 kilograms per cubic
meter glass has just under that at about
2,500 kilograms per cubic meter water is
998 kilograms per cubic meter which we
usually round to a thousand to keep it a
nice round number
gasoline seven hundred and thirty
kilograms per cubic meter and last but
certainly not least mercury sits at
about thirteen thousand six hundred
kilograms per cubic meter
holy mercury Batman I know right that's
just crazy larger numbers for density
means the substance is better at fitting
into a small space experiment time I'm
going to place this piece of ice skull
into this glass of cold water BAM
it floats I can even push it into the
water and when I release it floats back
up to the top yeah 917 is less than a
thousand so it floats gah that's a nice
trick but what happens if you can
replace the ice with ninja ducky oh
here's the problem
ninja ducky is made of soft rubber which
has a density
about 1100 kilograms per cubic meter
that's 100 bigger than the value for
water so the density rule says ninja
ducky should sink de vocht also if you
did this experiment in space you could
put ninja ducky anywhere in the water
and he wouldn't move yet he still has
the same density up there floating isn't
actually about density at all it's about
weight and pressure weight is how much
Earth pulls down on things with gravity
which is a very familiar concept to most
of us now let's see Ninja ducky is about
13 grams or so that comes to a weight of
about point zero three pounds or one
eighth of a Newton when you place him in
the water his weight pushes some of that
water out of the way see he submerged a
little however the water has weight too
so now ninja ducky in the water are in a
battle for supremacy to occupy that
space the heavier one will win in this
case that's the water and Ninja ducky
floats pressure comes in when you want
to be a little more mathematical that's
usually stated as a force distributed
over an area we can represent that with
a bunch of little forces like the ones
around this ball notice the forces are
bigger on the bottom than they are on
the top this is because pressure
increases with depth Skeptical consider
this scuba diver the pressure on the
diver is due to the weight of the water
above as the diver goes further down
there is more water above them and
therefore more pressure okay back to the
ball we can add all these little forces
together but we have to be careful about
direction so we'll split them all into
two pieces a quick look at the
horizontal pieces and you can see they
all cancel each other the vertical ones
don't cancel because they're bigger on
the bottom they push more up than they
do down so adding them together results
in this which is called a buoyant force
according to Archimedes principle the
buoyant force on an object is always
equal in strength to the weight of the
fluid being displaced by that object in
this case the fluid is the water and the
object is Ninja ducky remember we said
they were in a battle for supremacy
however in our committees principle the
fluid an object could really be anything
it doesn't even have to be an object
that floats this bowling ball has a
point force on it to the ball just
happens to be heavier than the water so
it sinks so the next time someone tells
you floating is because of density make
sure to correct them things float
because of weight we don't want to keep
perpetuating that horrible myth
so what's the coolest floating
experience you have ever had or seen
please share in the comments section and
until next time remember it's okay to be
a little crazy
you